Okay, let's start to wrap things up with a few final recommendations.
And we'll begin with Project Organization.
Right off the bat, I want to emphasize just how important Project Organization is in
your production.
Without it, things can get really messy very fast, so I highly recommend creating
nested folders and folder structures inside your Content Browser, and inside your Outliner
to maintain Project Organization as you work collaboratively in a production environment.
Typically, the studio you are working for will set this organizational standard.
However, when working on a production, it's recommended that you implement a level and
sub-level hierarchy that will allow for better organization and collaborative compartmentalization.
So your environment, or your persistent level, will contain anything that is universally
shared with the entire project.
Project sets or environments can live on their own sub-levels, and to clarify, when I'm
talking about levels, I'm referring to maps or worlds.
I do not mean level sequences.
There is a difference between these two assets.
Levels get organized into sub-levels and live under your persistent level depending
on what is actually needed for your project or departments.
For example, your main lighting setup should live on your persistent level, as it will
be utilized by the entire project or production.
Any level sequence-specific lighting setups should live in a Sequencer Lighting Comp sub-level,
so that anything specific to a level sequence that is spawnable should be connected to that
specific sub-level.
That way, it can get called in and out without affecting the persistent level and
causing problems between users working with that persistent level by having the Sequencer-specific
lighting turn on or off when that sub-level is not active.
Another actor class that has a profound impact on the setting up of action in Unreal
Engine is the use of a Subscene Track.
A Subscene Track essentially references an existing level sequence for the express purpose
of layering multiple actions together.
This type of organization allows you to create departmentalized level sequence organization
so that teams of artists can work together in real-time to construct distinct portions
of the action-based department or discipline and can be utilized in conjunction with
sub-level organization.
Just as we discussed for the lighting scenarios, cinematography can also do this for cine cameras,
character animation can have its own sub-scene, so all your characters and animations can
live on in an animation sub-level as well.
Level blueprints or level sequence blueprints, level sequence-specific effects, anything that
could be spawnable or triggered can also live on a sub-level under the persistent
level and also be organized in Sequencer through sub-scenes.
All of which can be checked out and shared between the teams and their members in a
production environment through your version control solution.
That's it for this section.
In our next section, we will continue with a few more of our final recommendations.